we're back live at the International Spy
Museum in downtown Washington DC about a
block from the FBI building and joining
us now is Antonio Mendez who is former
chief of disguise for the CIA and the
author of a couple of books the master
of disguise and also spied us mr. Mendez
thanks for joining us thanks for having
me what is the job of the chief of
disguise for the CIA
well I must also add that the second
book was co-authored with my wife and I
and she was also chief of disguise so
you're getting a twofer here even though
she's she's not here she's president you
know with the book yeah any case the
chief of disguise is in charge of one of
the technical operations activities of
the the CIA on the clandestine side
obviously it's not sort of thing you use
up on the hill for instance but in the
field in order to run operations
securely you need to be able to cloak
your operatives and that would be just
the the the officers like Peter earnest
who are in the field under some sort of
cover if they've got to go out and meet
a source a lot of times you're you're
disguising the officer and perhaps the
source for some reason but typically
it's so that you can secure operations
well we just had Peter earnest on the
set what would you do to change his
appearance
well obviously Peters is rather dapper
and and and well-groomed and an
official-looking if he were in the field
he might be in some official capacity
for the United States and then when he
went clandestine he would have to go out
on the streets and went in so what you
do is you look at what he is and then
try to figure out how to change each one
of those things that he is that are
recognizable in other words just sort of
take it as a list of things to work on
like maybe is his height maybe his
weight
maybe his hair coloring and that sort of
thing in his sex you know you can change
the sex of it well sometimes you have to
do that yeah well I want to let viewers
know the numbers are on the screen we
want you to call in we're just going to
continue our conversation here and we're
looking at an exhibit over here that
that you developed and indirect
what is this that we're seeing that's
wrong yeah what the the idea here is we
take a person who it was
curator for the for the museum help
build the exhibits and so forth she had
a certain style a certain pattern and
what we did is took three different
personas to to convert her to and and
the exhibit shows the steps that would
one would take to to to do that but each
one of those personas would have a me a
reason you you don't do disguise in a
vacuum it has to have context in other
words where you see the the street
person there you might want that person
to do surveillance on the street that's
a good good disguise for staying out on
the street for some time if you're if
you have sort of staked out at a certain
street corner as street people do you
would have stability of course we did
change your sex there too and if that's
the same woman that's the same woman
right there yes exactly and then and we
changed her a couple other ways there
too as you see you know there are
reasons for each one of those now are
you giving away state secrets by telling
us all this no actually what we're
looking at here is is what we'd call
commercially available techniques and
what what people like this organisation
like the CIA do is they they build on
commercial capabilities and and refine
them to whatever degree necessary in
order to meet the requirement so what
you what you're seeing in this display
is what would be 1970s Hollywood
techniques and what I was credited for
doing as chief of disguise and and then
those who came after me was to make
those techniques even better and so you
have to sort of imagine how good you can
get by throwing a lot of time and money
and talent at at a technique if it's
necessary to zero to five eight five
three eight eight zero if you're a
republican to zero to five eight five
three eight a one for democrats in to
zero to five eight five three eight
eight to four all others will begin
taking your calls right away mr. Mendez
you've disguised yourself before oh yeah
correct
one of one of the the things that a
disguise officer has to be able to do is
recommend things that will work and so a
fundamental part of that process is to
have done it all yourself and so you
kind of come to the customer if you want
to call them that as an expert and then
of course you don't do your work in a
vacuum or in in a laboratory in
Washington either you do it in the field
so a lot of times you have to disguise
yourself in order to get to the source
that you're trying to disguise for
instance the business of rescuing the
six out here from Iran I was the one who
went in to decide this guy isn't
document them because I was the expert
of course I had to I had to have a
disguise in a document to get there well
let's go back I know that according to
your bio that you conducted the secret
rescue of the diplomats in 1979 from
Tehran you disguised them as as what as
Hollywood Hollywood film crew
multinational film crew I was a European
they were Canadians but they each had a
job that related to location scouting
for a Hollywood production so we had to
create a production company you know go
out and find the real estate get people
to man the real estate go to the
Hollywood trade newspapers and take out
ads for our movie this is what we call
backstopping a cover so when we made
this elaborate backstopping so that if
somebody were to challenge them yeah as
they were trying to leave Iran they they
could verify in fact these are real
people so that's that's part of the
disguise if you will it's actually stage
management and you got in to Tehran how
did you get into Tehran well it was part
of the cover story a part of the cover
legend I went there to meet the rest of
the crew and I went there with with
another expert in exfiltration which is
what we call this kind of operation he
was the linguist I was the artist so to
speak and together we made the team that
would bring them out so he and I arrived
ostensibly to meet them there for a
meeting because we wanted to scout the
bazaar that was our that was our cover
story
we were we were doing this movie that
needed a bizarre like that in Tehran so
in case somebody were to challenge this
they would say you know why here and
we'd say well look at here here's the
script and this is the place and but
what we had to do is make it look like
the other six that we were rescuing had
arrived from the from the East Hong Kong
as I recall on Air France was the
ostensible carrier and we arrived from
the West
Zurich on Swiss Air and we picked those
flights because they arrived precisely
at the same time and if in fact they did
arrive on at the same time we knew that
the six would have come through the same
immigration officer got the same stamps
and signatures that we did that's what
we call parallel probate so we got we
collected the intelligence we needed to
finish off their their documents so it's
all part of this this whole business of
disguise and deception and delusion that
we can we're in - so were you disguised
at that point yes I was the production
manager and and I had a certain
nationality a certain persona I had a an
alias in fact there's a display in the
museum of that verisimilitude if you
will that the pocket litter the the
pieces that I carried the including the
full-page ad in variety some of the some
of the other pieces my business card and
so forth so I had it all the pocket
litter I had all the the costume and the
profile and pattern of this person that
I had created I had to get into that
that's a lot about what disguise is
about is getting into the into the role
and the other six and I had to then
coach each one of them in in their cover
so we looked at their true bio and we
matched their cover job to what their
experiences were so for instance the set
designer was was Kathy Stafford who had
an art background so when we arrived we
had the props for her the sketch pads
and and
set designs and so forth that she could
use as part of her cover and in my
portfolio which was an overt item we
made up in order to to conceal some of
the clandestine things I had the the
BIOS on each one of them as an overt
part of my portfolio for the movie and
so then I could just tear that out and
handle them and say there's your story
now to learn that you've got two days to
learn this and then you'll be you'll be
tested on it by us and sort of a hostile
interrogation before we go to the
airport and if you don't know every
detail then we will make sure that you
do and and were there problems well
there were a few the one of the issues
that those who made the decision to run
this operation or let me run this
operation we're concerned with is well
all six be willing to do this you know
because not everybody is into this kind
of thing and so there was varying kinds
of response to my my pitches to them if
you will but in fact as a group we ended
up creating a consensus and we all came
came out okay the other problems we had
were is this particular document still
used and if it is used the way it's
designed
could we get caught up in the airport
and that sort of thing so it's a little
bit of you know worried about that sort
of thing but we rent a lot of
intelligence-gathering operations to
make sure that that that was okay the
thirdly we want to make sure that the
airplane arrived that it was going to
leave and that sort of thing those are
sort of the fundamental things that you
worry about the worst thing that can
happen is to get all six in the airport
and there's no airplane you know and you
don't have a reservation isn't isn't
good so you make sure you have all these
logistical things in place but once we
got in through immigration found that
they weren't using that document the way
it was designed or they would have
caught us and we were in the departure
lounge and we had chosen Swiss Air
because had a good maintenance record
and was on time and so forth it was
early in the morning because we didn't
want a lot of people milling around the
airport all of a sudden we've got a
mechanic
problem and now we've got six people
sitting in the departure lounge being
scrutinized and we're wondering how long
is this gonna take so there's a lot of
those cliff hangers you know that that
you deal with but ultimately it worked
we were going up the ramp to the
airplane one of the six nudged me with
his elbow and he said you guys think of
everything don't you any pointed to the
nose of the airplane and let it across
the nose of the airplane was the word
our gal which is a region in Switzerland
well the name of our movie was Argo and
it was so close it was one of those
omens that you always look for in an
operation of this sort and once we saw
that we said it's gonna be okay because
we still had to leave around an airspace
once you get on the airplane you still
have the problem of leaving their
airspace first call up for Antonio
Mendez Worcester Massachusetts good
morning good morning I'm a criminal
justice major at Westfield State College
in Westfield mass and this subject
fascinates me in point of fact I never
thought of this particular aspect of it
you know the professor's talk to us more
about the needing more computer sciences
scientists to be able to decipher the
codes etc and they need to have more
money to teach the Middle Eastern
languages and the professor that taught
me terrorism was recently called back
into service because because of this
9/11 for the next two years and the
aspect of of a disguise hasn't been
discussed that much in class so so this
really interests me and I really
appreciate your coming on c-span to
discuss it mr. Mendez well thank you
yeah this guy's is fundamental
just it's probably the most used
tradecraft of all but it's sort of
arcane too and it's not sort of people
think people really know about next call
Boston good morning
like my question is how is modern
technology changing your job I would
think in some ways it's making it more
difficult in some ways it's easier thank
her to eat then yes there's always a
trade-off between the progress of modern
technology and the ability to use good
and secure tradecraft in the past I
might add that in during the Cold War
for instance there was a lot of these
the intelligence organizations pushing
technology making the batteries smaller
more powerful make the cameras radios
more efficient etc etc then all of a
sudden the commercial technologies start
overtaking us and and what that meant is
that even the smallest intelligence
organizations or counterintelligence
organizations go out enquire the same
sort of level of technology we had and
that that was a grace to threat and of
course these days with the internet and
and computer technology etc etc it's
much harder to sustain for instance a
cover in other words create a persona
and have it withstand scrutiny because
it's so easy to check an identity by
using modern technology so that there's
always the the trade-offs you know with
technology but it's my part of the
business was in technical services and
we were always imagining new technology
or seeing it in James Bond films or so
forth and we were always pushing pushing
the law of physics if you will okay
we've talked about Hollywood makeup and
I think that's what most people think of
when they think of disguise and chief of
disguised what has changed can you give
us any specific examples well that gets
into the sources and methods of
technology what I can say is if you look
at the citation that was written about
me
on the 50th anniversary of the CIA I was
credited with pushing the technology of
disguise so that that CIA officers could
could work more and more securely and
more more realistically
the most hostile places in the world I
would give you a timeline I first got
involved in 1971 while I was in in the
Far East and in South Asia I did things
out there in concert with with
technicians and researchers and and
Hollywood experts that led me to become
chief of disguise by 1974 so that's you
know like in three years by 1976 we
rewrote the modus operandi for CIA and
Moscow which is in those days Wimbledon
Center Court and so we really changed
the way that we could operate and it was
it was a lot about creating illusion and
deception by using disguise and other
techniques it's all be only that precise
Fayetteville North Carolina good morning
ma'am you got to turn down the volume on
your TV it's the mute button and go
ahead with your comment hi I was for
Special Forces Command at Fort Bragg and
I've been studying the OSS which is in
our 50 50 year history of Special Forces
and in particularly in particular I've
been studying a man who named life bangs
ball who was operating immediately after
World War two and in Berlin and he he I
read a book about disguises at that time
and apparently do you know anything
about hazelnuts that were you could
drill a hole through and quickly shove
them into your nose to create a whole
different persona just by by flattening
your nose and that sort of thing and did
spies do spies of this era and that area
that they carry on their person quick
change type apparatus is what you're
what you're referring to is is a
technique that was in a OSS disguise
manual that was written in 1944 and it
was actually created by consultants in
Hollywood for the OSS operatives who
were serving behind enemy lines they
realized very quickly if they got in
trouble if their cover started
you rode while they were in fortress
Europe or wherever what they needed to
do is be able to get away and change
their look in order to escape and evade
as we would say that's he and II that's
disguise for escape and evasion and and
the hazelnut was was one of the
techniques was in this manual we
couldn't send them a bunch of material
that and because they couldn't conceal
matter carry it with him so what we had
to do in this manual is is tell them how
to use found materials the hazelnuts
were to change the shape of your nose
and the idea was you drilled tiny holes
through these hazelnuts so you could
still breathe but you you had them in
your pocket a couple hazelnuts with
holes drilled through them and you push
them up your nose and and change the
sacred nose actually changing the shape
of somebody's face is a game of
millimeters and a lot of times it's done
from within
for instance we make a device called a
plumper that goes up under the lip or
down along the gum line gum line and if
you remember Marlon Brando for instance
in godfather he had it at an old man's
chin like this that was then with a
plumper so a lot of things are done
within some things are done on the
outside and the hazelnuts is part of
that technique Fairfield California good
morning good morning you're on the air
yeah this is :
pipe down New Mexico oh go ahead sorry I
was wondering I purchased a book at a
library sale called I led three lives by
Herbert filbert and I was wondering if
you had any information I remember my
parents when I was young back in the
early 50s
about this man and I just wonder if you
have any information on him and reading
Antonio Mendez well yeah I remember as a
adolescent the television show made on
that book I led three lives and I
watched it with interest because I was
just becoming at the age where I started
understanding about spies and counter
spies and
herbert filbert was an FBI CounterSpy
agent and what he was doing was
infiltrating these groups that were
considered to be threat a threat to our
national security these are like
American Communist Party cells and so
forth but it was very exciting probably
one of the first things that I thought
of was when it when it came to having an
opportunity to become an intelligence
officer I must tell you the thing that
that drew me into the CIA was the word
intrigue and I can tell you that every
day that I was there every day of 25
years that I was there was is intriguing
as as you would expect in fact more
intriguing than the James Bond films or
the Mission Impossible shows so this
book could be worth reading yes because
it's true last call McAllen Texas good
morning McAllen Texas you there we don't
have our last call we McAllen that's it
last chance go ahead okay just two
things one wanted to see if we're if I
purchase two copies of you books where I
might be able to get them signed to give
out as a gift and second comment is I
just visited the Spy Museum last week
when I was there for a high school
reunion and I was fascinating very
impressive but one of the questions I
have is have you ever had to use
disguise for internal things such as
Aldrich Ames or Robert Hansen and just
curious as to how that's affecting those
kinds of things when we have internal
problems well in fact the museum is
intriguing as well and I'm glad you
liked it is the question on where to get
the books signed
I should mention that they are available
on our website the master of disguise
comm and in there there's a block that
you check for the inscription did you
want we even put one of our own custom
design book lights in it but they are
available at bookstores and online as
well so anyway thanks for the
opportunity to mention that finally yes
disguises sometimes they're used for
what you might call internal purposes in
other words if you've got a mole in your
mist you might use this guys as a way to
find what they're up to and in here mr.
Mendez is two books by dust and the
master of disguise did you need to get
permission from the CIA to write some of
the stuff in here that you did
absolutely submitted to the public
really publications Review Board of the
CIA and they work with you to make sure
you don't have classified information in
there and sometimes it's it's a long
process I think collectively those two
books have probably been reviewed 12
times as I recall Antonio Mendez thank
you so much for joining us this morning
thanks for having me and thanks to the
spy museum for letting us come over here
this morning we appreciate it very much
and tomorrow on the Washington journal
we will be live from 7:00 to 10:00 a.m.
we will be talking about the War Powers
Act and on Sunday the German ambassador
ambassador ition gur will be joining us
to take your calls and to talk about us
German relations and the whole situation
with Iraq have a great Labor Day weekend
we'll see you tomorrow